what's up guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out a video from BuzzFeed that
I was sent by a few people and I was
like oh I'm definitely checking this one
out it is men watch porn with porn stars
now if anyone out there knows me or is a
fan of the channel they know I'm the fan
of porn I have a porn addiction it
interferes in my relationships it causes
me to prefer it over sex and I'm going
to counseling with my girlfriend now so
she can learn how to deal with the
addiction let's watch this contains I
don't watch wedding and it's not even
that hi hi I'm Paris Kennedy I'm Danny
Wilde and I am a porn star my back and
I'm definitely not a porn star I'm about
to watch some porn with Ellie Hayes that
she stars in I'm a straight guy and I'm
about to watch some gay porn I don't
really watch straight porn though I
don't know this is the point where I
admit that like I feel like I've almost
definitely seen important with you in it
before my expectations are pretty high
this is a really old same I do act quite
a bit in this it's broken down as intro
[ __ ] sex once x2 I also just noticed
this is one take that's insane that's
like Birdman no kissy for girl I'm sorry
I just keep getting stranded by this
brain it's kind of like flesh just nice
kissing - there's the PP I think it's
awesome that porn stars say PP well
spank it's getting good today direct you
to do this bank or was that just like
now I'm in it I'm feeling it it was in
the script wieners and guys do you like
it when they talk to you like you're
like really good at sucking dick thank
you oh my god that means I'm oh there's
three guys here yes yes so many just
like appendages that's a really big
penis this is amazing all these have
beautiful penis thank you how much time
you guys sit before like draw this out
like a football players up to the camera
guy really your abs must be killer like
your core strength holy [ __ ] you're like
in the gym just like
year that's a typical line look at how
much you're sweating holy the roller
skates are making me taller so yes sippy
toes are you being spit-roasted well I
don't have a dick in my butt our most
porn stars like like circumcised or not
circumcised is data
I'm actually not circumcised I could
tell me I did I did that is something I
was able to tell very quickly oh wow oh
my god we are really going for it right
now
how well do you know these these guys
Madame it seems very professional
oh then I just met them and I can't you
just like dive right in yeah totally I
would be nervous if I had to do like a
kissing scene that doesn't take a toll
on you physically you know I mean I know
my body well enough that when I'm ready
to be done I'm like time you do this
especially what's happening in our ear
are narrow and then like some moans do
you have to like do that to your coochie
cat no it's kind of just for the visual
for the viewer like are you enjoying
this let's freeze on this close-up of
your testicles this is almost like
abstract art I could see that like hung
up and like some old person's apartment
they don't even know what it is it's not
my my style but I appreciate it I get it
I'm pretty familiar with all the
equipment you guys are working with you
know he's about to come show it like
five times like in slow motion it's
gonna come on the roller skate alright
well that was a thing we did I think
it's really interesting like to hear
like how these actually get put together
that's not as awkward as I thought it
would be there's normal guy isn't dude
I'm commend you for actually sitting
here and doing that because I couldn't
finish somebody do like watch me ask
that ha ha I would be like you like it
like that that's what you do I'm not
gonna lie I have a little like softy oh
wow it's like such a big compliment from
a gay guy like I want to cry I'm glad
mr. Sahni
watching was well thank you a special
for me too I just show you some of my
videos but I think they're not as
exciting I think that's only fair right
but I do get naked anybody you got a
nice little bulge in there yeah boy
start respect my balls I'm into that
that would be cool to do I would love to
watch porn with the porn actor next to
me that would be so hot
dad allie Haze chick man
trust me I've seen a video or two with
her but you know you know like I've seen
like documentaries about the porn
business I've seen interviews of porn
stars and then I've seen videos about
after born and what porn industry is
really like but then you meet some
people in the porn business you're like
wow these are just like businessmen or
businesswoman who show their tits but
some of them are just business yeah some
of them are like [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
depressed and [ __ ] whatever but some of
them are like they know well they're
well aware of what they're doing and
they just look at it as work you know
there's this one porn star male porn
star named James Dean de en and this
dude total [ __ ] Pro I've seen
interviews with him read articles
professional and he does a lot of kinds
of sex man gangbangs double anal photo
shows James Dean sometimes I just wish
my girlfriend would have sex with James
Dean just once it's cool to see that
these porn stars are just like chill
yeah it's just what I do for a living
and some people might not be aware that
that's how a lot of porn actors operate
but I am I've seen Boogie Nights anyway
guys thanks for tuning into the real
rejects if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter but mainly follow us on vine
because if we get enough followers we
can get product placement
Wow how did I happen to come across this
shoutout
Jacqueline Miller hey Ryan just wanted
to say that no one touches you for
watching porn and that you guys and
other youtubers are inspiring me to
become a youtuber too for I like how
first sentence is no one should judge
you for watching porn and you're an
inspiration starting up a gaming and
sketches can I have a shout-out PS Ryan
if you see this I'm just using my mom's
account to get shout out so you can see
this use my actual name Jeffrey Miller
Jaclyn Miller hold on a second you might
be a MILF sub lady Jeffrey Miller dude
if you want to start a YouTube channel
you go for it but I gotta let you in on
the secret ingredient you got to be
relaxed in front of the camera how do
you get relaxed you jerk off to a lot of
porn a lot of drinking I drift off at
least three times before filming and
then I swallow my come because it's
protein gets the brain working sharp so
Jeffrey if there's any advice I could
give you it is swallow your own come